[Music]
hey
hey what happened he killed her they
[ __ ] killed her man what i just
decided to help out you know i got some
intel and the bullet just trying to cut
him off and
oh [ __ ] they just ran right into it i'm
so sorry oh just like i tried to stop
him i cut it
up okay hey hey so you're saying there's
there's people with the turrets look at
me
you're saying they're not alone i think
so all right did you get a good look at
them or not really
i was too busy worrying about lucy right
lucy but i think they went off in the
storm drains can't be too far
ah who invited you exactly
starlight listen what i did was
unforgivable
i'm going to do everything in my power
to renew my light
not just for you but for all the female
people that i've offended renew your
light did you just [ __ ] join the
church of the collective
maybe you're an idiot hey easy on the
religious persecution okay
new girl starlight maybe one day you can
welcome me back into the seventh
i know my root is long and hard are you
serious
there is no [ __ ]
way you're coming back there's no need
for language
all right enough we do not have time for
this
look i am with you sister but first we
have to go get the terrorists okay
all right everyone in the tunnels yeah
everyone in the tunnels not you
butcher what happened
my wife she's alive
what's holding the gift of somebody and
right now
we're in a little bit of trouble
are you [ __ ] with us
listen this is a [ __ ] mess
we're the most wonderful heads in the
country
we got soup terrorists
and we got no superheroes hi
i'm stormfront who i'm the new girl
oh god so what's your big plan
don't take that there we go can i get my
wife back
we're in of course we're in
we blow it up in that air
more super terrorists will come
for all we know these maniacs could be
waiting for their chance to kill us all
[Applause]
who the [ __ ] are you i'm just trying to
help
really how we are in a war
but we can fight back with an army
of supermen millions strong
no don't be a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ]
tits
she's got a whole army of soups
christmas
i need more soup
[Applause]
all right what do we do we can't just
kill everyone that's exactly what we're
gonna do
oh great cool totally one two three
we just need to keep our [ __ ] together
okay you guys go ahead you guys go ahead
i'm good
all right hands in the air like you just
don't care
kill
[Music]
you